and let's jump into that first story
from the New York Post the U.S buys
millions of monkey pox vaccines after
Massachusetts confirms case the U.S has
ordered 13 million additional doses of
the monkey pox vaccine after a
Massachusetts man contracted the rare
but potentially severe virus the massive
119 million dollar order of the genius
Jabs which can be used to treat both the
monkey pox virus and smallpox
was created by the biotechnology company
Bavarian Nordic according Newsweek in
2015 the CDC uh in San Francisco
approved the use of the genius as a
vaccine for the rare virus monkeypox
versus government 58 blah blah blah
symptoms include fever headache body
aches swollen lymph nodes chills
exhaustion and in some cases rashes
within recent years there have been
several flare-ups of the disease several
of them in the UK two cases were
imported in the U.S in 2021. however if
you head over to the Wikipedia entry for
the 2022 monkey pox outbreak
I think perhaps we could
um ask some questions about why it
already has a Wikipedia entry and what's
happening this year where uh this kind
of story could greatly benefit someone
and well it's politics now before we get
into all that they're saying the virus
strain is the West African plague of the
monkey pox virus which has a mortality
rate my understanding is less than one
percent
they say however they do say uh although
usually uh monkey pox generally presents
with similar symptoms to smallpox
although usually milder however the case
fatality rate for monkey pox may still
be as high as high as 10 percent without
prompt treatment if you go down we have
the UK Spain Portugal the US Sweden
Italy Belgium Canada and France now in
Canada and France there are suspected
cases not confirmed cases but in the
seven other countries we have confirmed
cases totaling 34. perhaps nothing right
perhaps this is just something happens
every year and maybe the media is
latched down to it because it'll
generate clicks maybe it can be used to
scare people for an election or maybe
they just purchase 13 million monkey pox
vaccines for a reason
I told Luke Krakowski within the show or
what was this before January I thought
we'd see a lockdown this year because of
the midterms and the Democrats didn't
have anything else he said no they're
gonna they're not gonna do it they're
not gonna do it they can't tonight and
then after a few months like you know
what I think Luke's right they're
pulling the lockdowns back
I still think it would be a stretch that
they would lock down over this but when
you've got a virus and they're going
around saying a 10 mortality rate I
wonder
if they'll actually try and pull off
another lockdown
I think we need to take all potential
pandemics very seriously but um the
issue here right now is that the trust
in the CDC is at an all-time low so I
think information surrounding this virus
is going to be very untrusted and maybe
rightfully so again we already have like
a Wikipedia page about this
um I think at one point it said it's
endemic in Nigeria
well some people from Nigeria have
gotten it but the West African played of
the monkey pox virus is uh what they're
saying now yeah so I remember thinking
originally when they had like the 14
days to stop the spread that we wouldn't
be able to sustain that in our public
wouldn't be able to you know wouldn't
put up with that and I was so off base
with what that was so I I don't know
what's going on with this what do you
guys think
well I think uh people should learn
enough from past two years what is our
trust level today on the media or our
government agencies right there's it's
very low
and I still have lots of questions never
got answered and we're still waiting for
more and more evidence more truths to
come out
and this this kind of stuff you know
like we we have always always left you
know with lots of stuff in the past and
I think people are ready to move on have
a normal life back there's still lots of
mental health issues our children our
people have not even got resolved yet I
have a friend who's got long Covey she
cannot have Solutions she's still
coughing
so I I'm just not really ready for this
you know I hope people will have more
questions instead of jump into what the
media is saying
yeah I would agree and I think a lot of
people aren't going to jump to what the
media is saying even if this does turn
out to be something substantial and it
really is a risk people aren't going to
be willing to trust the media in the CDC
and for good reason because they spent
the last two years completely
undermining any credibility they may
have had with the American people I'm
just I'm just imagining fauci you know
when the news broke it was like thank
you and he's like he's he opens his
closet and this is a whole bunch of
different masks puts his top hat on his
Cane he starts singing but he's like he
picks out his tie and then he also pulls
out all he's had all the masks lined up
and there's like different pens and I'll
take this one and then he puts it on and
he gets ready and how many people will
still call him now King I don't know
well he did say he would resign if
Donald Trump got elected really yeah so
everybody was like okay so a vote for
Donald Donald vote against fauci and Joe
Biden yeah why would he campaign for
Trump like that seriously I'm kind of
questioning who this could potentially
help politically this becoming a big
story in the news and the only people I
could write like initially think that
this could help is the people who effed
up big time during the covet pandemic
and you know with with certain lockdowns
who does this help you know we kind of
memory hold you know the origin of covet
and holding people responsible for covid
who may have let it out or you know
helped exacerbate the issue around the
planet so this could potentially help
them I also know it's it's called monkey
pox so maybe this is just like an
anti-monkey lobbyist group because I
know with you know the China virus we
were concerned about hate crimes because
of that and now why are they calling
this monkey pox a little bit insensitive
because it was first isolated monkeys oh
that makes too much sense so I pulled up
right well I was told Corona was first
isolated in a bat that's right so right
so when I pulled up Reddit you take a
look at the comments someone comments on
why he says I don't understand why so
many comments are being removed and the
response is all I know is covid-19
started just like this news of
infections all over Europe then to the
US but it's contained and then all of a
sudden bam lockdown I expect anything to
happen nowadays
and then uh someone said well we have
two years of contact tracing so we
should be able to easily find that
exposure oh yeah right also wait I just
want to make a point I was making a joke
earlier but I actually still want to
correct this I said isolated about it
was never isolated in a bad they just
said it came from a bat when they were
talking about in New York City they just
changed the covet alert to high and
people are already prepared to start
masking again so if this spreads even a
little bit some places in the country
are willing to lock down over relatively
small things again and and are happy to
so in China in China one quarter of
population under Covey lockdown for all
Makwa you know it's like what talk about
something else is coming you're talking
about 18 trillion dollars economy in
China one quarter of them are under
lockdown and welcome to food shortages
supply issues and people have no access
to Medicine Medical Care and they're
committed suicide and we don't see the
lots of report on that and condemn this
kind of inhuman treatment of of their
citizens and now we'll talk about this
is like it's an insane world you know we
talked about the uh the rat hope
experiment before
so this was where the guy puts the rat
in the cylinder full of water the rat
can't get out then within 15 minutes it
just gives up and then sinks to the
bottom and dies
but then he puts another rat in after
right right when it's about to give up
and it starts sinking he pulls it out
dries it off lets it rest picks it up
puts it back in this time the rats would
swim for an average of 60 hours
because they thought there was hope that
if they just waited somebody would would
pull them out and I'm feeling like this
is what we're bumping into after coven
you know we get two years of this
Insanity everybody's about to lose their
mind and then also everything goes back
to normal now you get monkey pox and
what's to say I'm not saying it will
happen if they lock down people are
going to be like I can handle I can
handle the lockdown we know if we just
wait long enough eventually we'll get
through this and this time it'll be five
years
five years of weird lockdown people
starving locked in their homes doors
welded shut like what's going on in
China right now
I know it's like two years ago right
Wuhan lockdown like 30 million people
now Shanghai is 25 meaning and the whole
country 45 cities you're talking about
370 million people under lockdown and
they censor all the information like how
many people are dying of lack of food
Medical Care and access to medicine and
how many people committed suicide there
are lots of videos on wheelchair as soon
as I get to it say no it's gone this
violates our regulation it sounds like
there's some notice I'll get from
Facebook you know and it just it's so
sad for me to say because I have lots of
friends in Shanghai I went to college
there I worked there for seven years
total time in Shanghai and imagine those
people who supported economical reform
had a good life and retire now and they
have money and they cannot buy food and
I have one friend even commented I I get
it now why Americans hold on to their
guns
even Chinese get it now it's like
because they got locked down by the
wires electrical wires on their steps to
go out so they cannot get out you can
get some fresh air and totally rely on
government delivery food who get the
priorities if you have 25 million people
of course people who are high up with
connections it's Madness and the farmers
see their vegetable dying of getting
rotten because there's a total breakdown
between the food supply and to the end
user customers so roads are blocked you
have to have mass massive testing so
people cannot get to the food and the
people have power guess what they do
they hoard food also sell for very high
prices and and those people who wear
white clothes you see all those terrible
videos guess their new names it's a
white guards instead of red guards under
most China White guards yes and they're
total nuts very suckish one girl was
raped by living alone and the white guy
coming and not just raped her but also
kill her mom is like please help my
daughter is dead
and it's like it's so heartbroken you
know that's why I'm running I I don't
want this ever come to America
I think New Hampshire is relatively safe
but it's it's mostly because of people
like you in the free state project
because New Hampshire is moving fur like
closer and closer to Freedom further and
further away from The Establishment the
authoritarianism but I would not be
surprised if uh we got a lockdown out of
this and it's early it's early this
could be a blip and then within a week
There's No story it's gone and it was
like false alarm everybody I just kind
of feel like when I saw that they
already made a Wikipedia entry for it
I'm like somebody with time and energy
decided to make an entry for an outbreak
when we're at 34 cases is that really a
global outbreak is that why I guess so I
guess so so uh I'm just I just wonder
was it plans a lot bigger than just oh
recently you show up in Wikipedia think
about the former KGB guy urine what he
said 40 years ago he died you know and
he said the Communists will infiltrate
into America and they're gonna take two
generations to bring down United States
of America why two generations is it
well you got to have four steps number
one step is a demoralize a society then
destabilize it then you go through
crisis and crisis situations then you're
trying to normalize it but when they're
trying to normalize it
you'll right and freedom are all gone
it's their normalization I'm terrified
to say this is craziness going on in the
world I know New Hampshire is great
that's why I moved there but I'm worried
about the whole country because I have
three children who are born this country
they're living in other states right now
yeah I'm not I'm not sure we can we can
pull back I think maybe we've gone off
the edge of the cliff a long time ago
and now it's a free fall
right with just uh we've been
demoralized now we're destabilized and I
don't think there is a coming back
because
there's just too many people in this
country that don't care to know but want
power and when you take ignorant people
lazy ignorant people who desire power
because they think they're smarter than
you they destroy things
these are the kind of people that you
know we're in a car and we're driving
straight towards the edge about to go
off the cliff and you got the person on
the right side of the person on the left
side the person on the right keeps
saying stop turn turn the person on the
left is like no I'm right I know what
I'm doing and then straight off the edge
of the cliff but they're part of the
plan is called the indoctrulation of the
youth take away parental rights kids
belong to this state and believe in
Marxism and socialism and free stuff and
guess who are they today
social justice Warriors work activists
or whatever you call them
I don't know it's really we have to
blame ourselves our educational system
really when you think about it Hong Kong
people young people go out to risk their
life to protest want to democracy one
freedom and and even want to say
commitment our young people here please
have more gun control take my guns away
well this is I agree and sadly it's not
just the young people it's the older
people who don't really care about the
young and aren't really interested in
protecting the youth so for example we
have a CDC report which said youth
suicide attempts soared during the
pandemics I mean you lock kids in their
homes you take away normal social
settings and situations they're going to
be more likely to get depressed we also
know that they had Mass mandates for
children in New York children were the
last people who were still required to
wear a mask they're still required to
wear them now right now exactly and so
adults aren't doing their responsibility
and protect acting children from this
kind of stuff and you would think those
are the most vulnerable of our society
little young kids who don't know what's
going on lose a valuable time of
learning years I heard the kids who
under four they lost two years to speak
properly because everybody's wear a mask
and you know hide their faces cannot
develop their social skills and they're
going through speech therapy right now
it's like even article published by the
Atlantic it's like my kids need a speech
therapy exactly and so I think we've
seen this one of the the strategies of
the communist movement is to try to
break down the family and so it's going
in both directions firstly you see it is
very much the case that children don't
respect their parents anymore and they
look to the states to find solutions
they look to the state to find solutions
to problems rather than to the family
structure and also of course as I just
mentioned parents are not really
interested in protecting their children
either this really goes in both
directions the family has very much been
chipped away at from every angle I want
to make a point on that but I do want to
make a point on the speech thing real
quick you ever watch a TV show and the
volume is just a little too low but you
can tell what they're saying by how
their mouth is moving yeah and then you
like look down at your phone and now all
of a sudden the clear words become
performance
that seeing the mouth movements really
does we are we are verbal and visual
communicators vocal and visual and all
these kids now these little kids all
they saw was masks so their their brain
was like not getting the full
Communications experience now these kids
like you mentioned they're in therapy or
they're going to grow up and they're
going to be stunted yeah so going back
to what you were saying about the family
I mean uh absolutely and I agree that a
lot of parents
um well I'll say it myself I don't think
a lot of parents care about their kids
no I think they uh care about them in a
superficial way but I'm surprised to
hear these stories every day where it's
like look we had this video from Libs of
tick tock where a mother says my 15 year
old daughter was given pornographic
material to do an assignment done and
she was mortified and when she tried
reading the assignment they told her to
stop talking because it was too vulgar
for the meeting and this is like the
fifth Story we've seen about this and
she was like my daughter was given this
where were the other parents huh why was
just this one mother speaking about this
where were how many parents how many
kids are in a school right you got
you've got what a thousand maybe or more
shouldn't there be hundreds of parents
showing up being like why were my
children given this no they're not
they're not showing up they have no idea
it's it's insane to me just look I I get
it I don't have kids but my when I grew
up my parents asked me about school all
the time how was school what did you
learn and they would ask me questions
and they would give me answers just the
idea that you'd come home and they'd be
like meh and have no idea what the
teachers were that were grooming you for
or I know it's sad that when we raise
our three children you know we they went
to public school and in when Douglas
County Colorado we know that we have to
have family dinner together every night
and then we talk to them about school
and then we ask them actually tough
questions so you have to tell us what's
going on what the teacher you know
taught them so we have to basically
program them you have to do this as
families you know if you cannot afford
private school you can afford a home
school you gotta have a conversation
with your kids you know I you cannot
just treat school as babysitters go to
school hours hours long and we do our
business we do our work and the kids
come home there's a very funny memes
like some kids go to college at the age
of 18 and come back look like total Car
works
well there goes you still don't know
money you pay for it I
I just I I wonder if it's it's a
communist plot or if it's just
dominoes falling over if you look at uh
the 70s with um women's Liberation right
A lot of people don't understand I think
it was 1974. pre-1974 women couldn't get
credit cards without their husband's
signature so it's like you're not
married too bad something like that fact
should be on that one yeah but I've
heard a lot of those stories but we do
know that in the late 70s more and more
women started out into the workplace all
of a sudden the workforce doubles well
if the supply of workers doubles but the
demand stays the same workers are going
to be losing at because they have no
negotiating power all of a sudden now uh
women who could work
didn't have to now have to because wages
are stagnant and now you need two
incomes to support your family now
without anyone to take care of the
family you need someone to put your kids
but you can't afford daycare so Public
Schools come around now your kids are
handed off to the state the next step is
these kids are raised by
the state employees like at literal
agents of the state and they grow up
now you've got the millennial generation
which is split between many I don't know
average people and then a whole bunch of
pro-government socialists
kids uh I'm not going to call them
adults they're they're still they're
they're old children we'll call it that
and now they're advocating for an
expansion upon the government
controlling more and more your lives but
why they were raised by the government
they weren't raised by their parents
they were raised in government
institutions
that's freaky to me and their teachers
are trained by Marxist professors in
teachers colleges you know how many
teachers College in the country those
teachers can become our kids teachers
and when I when I go to school talk
about cultural revolution how many
people died on their Mouse communism and
all the details Horrors some teachers
who are democratic oh really we never
knew that so if they don't know how do
they teach our kids real history or is
that there like a left side of story of
a history 100 million people died under
100 Years of Communism and and some
people will say they did not do it right
they did not do the socialism companies
like how many people are you going to
experiment with this ideology I wonder
if you get Bill Gates in private you
know that he knew that he was safe what
he would say about the Communist
dictatorships he's a guy who's given
talk saying we need to reduce population
growth and I and I wonder because
certainly the Communists
effectively reduced population growth
you know by Exterminating hundreds 100
million people which is horrifying
another one child policy as well right
right and starving to death I'm not I'm
not accusing Bill Gates of anything I'm
genuinely curious what he might think of
that because if he's a utilitarian and
he seems to be I'd imagine he'd be like
well you know a positive outcome I guess
by the way I just want to mention so I
did just a little bit of Googling here
since you mentioned the thing about
women not being able to get credit cards
what I'm reading is that it was the case
that before there was an
anti-discrimination law a bank could
deny them a credit card I'm not sure how
often it happens one website is saying
that they could face a barrage of
questions when trying to get a credit
card that men wouldn't face but I'm not
like seeing any numbers on how common
but also people didn't understand this
because I see feminists say all the time
they're like did you know that women
couldn't get credit cards unless their
husband signed off on it it's like did
you know that women mostly weren't
working so the bank would be like how do
you intend to pay for this and they'd be
like my husband has a job and they'd be
like okay well then your husband needs
to certify this that doesn't sound as
nefarious now does it thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show Happy happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there